When we think about the civil rights
movement in the United States,
most people immediately think of Martin
Luther King Jr and almost everyone can
recite the beginning of
his either dream speech,
but the story of another
human rights activists,
Malcolm X is often
sensitive in history costs.
He is misunderstood as somebody preached
hate and violence against white people
and some believe that if young
people watched his speeches,
it could actually be rather
dangerous because of that,
his memory is often swept under the
rug while everyone knows him by name.
Not Enough people know the
true story of Malcolm x.
He was one of the most influential
Americans who ever lived and his legacy,
it's still that goes on to this very day.
Without him,
the u s and maybe even the entire world's
would be a really different place in
today's buying graphics.
We're going to talk about the
incredible life of Malcolm x.
A boy named Malcolm little was
born on May the 19th 1925 in Omaha,
Nebraska.
He was one of seven children belonging
to Louise and Earl little Malkin's.
Barron's taught their children all
about the history of slavery and the
importance of rising above their
circumstances. Now can any siblings,
they were all extremely well behaved
even from a young age because they knew
that they were trying to represent
their race in a positive light.
His father oh believes in the teachings
of a man called Marcus Garvey black
nationalist leader who
preached that African Americans
should be self sufficient
when it came to running their own
farms and their own businesses. Oh,
was a baptist minister who pushed for
desegregation between white and black
people.
Because of this,
the family received death threats
from the KKK on a daily basis,
so they were constantly
moving just to stay alive.
In 1929 oh little bought his family a
four Acre farm in Lansing, Michigan,
which had a very good
neighborhood with great schools.
The only issue was that they were
the only black family in town. Now,
hey isn't something that children
are born with. So Americans,
classmates in kindergarten treated
him just like everyone else.
Malcolm's favorite game was Robin hoods
and he always invited his friends over
to run through the fields and the forests
of his family farm pretending to steal
from the rich and give to the poor.
Eventually the racist
members of the community.
They caught wind of this black family
living a comfortable middle class life and
while I didn't like it,
the neighbors complained saying that
black people should not be allowed to own
so much land even though there was no
law saying that they couldn't live there.
The local council voted on the issue and
degreed that the little family had to
move all this all refuse to leave saying
that his family had every right to stay,
that Lansing Michigan was
home to an offshoot of the
KKK called the Black Legion
is that of wearing silly white
robes with pointed hoods.
They dressed up and even
sillier pirate costumes.
You really couldn't make
these things up one night,
the list of family or
work to an explosion.
As these white supremacists held
bombs of their house earlier,
newies had to wake up the
children and get them to safety.
Despite the explosions,
which could certainly be heard
for miles local firefighters.
They never showed up to help and
the house it burned to the grounds.
In the morning,
I'll this or confronted the local police.
He accused them of being
members of the Black Legion.
The police responded by arresting and
vast and saying that he burned down the
house to receive an insurance settlement.
The charges,
they were late to drop even after this,
they refuse to leave because they wanted
to be an example of the black family
who stood their ground and didn't give
up without a fight. Unfortunately,
their strength and resolve it was not
enough to convince the citizens of Lansing
that they were worthy of living there.
When Malcolm was just six years old,
L's body was found crushed on the
tracks of a street car, the car,
enough rules in accidents.
The police said that he committed suicide
and his autobiography of Malcolm x
explains that his father had sustained
injuries and all consistent with the
street car accidents.
Despite the coroner statements to the
Insurance Company that tells l policy
refuse to pay. Louise. Due to that
contention that ELLs death was a suicide,
Malcolm's mother had a very difficult
time raising eight children alone.
She sold many of their
belongings into which,
so for people in town in order to make
an income, she rented their lands,
other local farmers, but there was
never enough money to go around.
She was a proud woman,
though she lived by our principals and
she never asked for a handout from anyone.
The family, they seem not to go on
welfare, but as the years went on,
the weight of the responsibility
continue to tear away.
Atta Louise knew that
the white people in town,
they hated her and that the men
responsible for her husband's death.
They were I think twice by,
she was constantly afraid that someone
would come off to and to children even
though her fears were
completely justified.
She was diagnosed as paranoid and that
local police committed her to a mental
institution.
Malcolm was 13 when his mother was taken
away and he and his six siblings were
split up and sent to
orphanages and foster homes.
They kept in touch by writing letters
to another and swore that they would all
reunite again someday just
by all of these setbacks.
Malcolm still had a lot of ambition for
himself and he never forgot the lessons
that his parents taught him.
In the eighth grade,
he was a straight a students and at the
top of his class he was intelligent,
charismatic, and they had a
passion for public speaking.
What do you went to high school?
He joined the debate team and
continue downing a 4.0 GPA.
One of his teachers asked everyone what
they wanted to be when they grew up and
Malcolm said that he
wanted to become a lawyer.
The teacher said that this was impossible,
saying that black people were simply
not allowed to be liars is steep.
Show up for the responded. One of life's
first needs is for us to be realistic.
You need to think of something you can be.
Why don't you plan on
carpentry in Rihanna?
[inaudible] name's Malcolm bl and had
already become America's first black
lawyer in the 18 hundreds but of course
Malcolm could not have known that he
believes his teacher was right.
He was still living in foster care and
he no longer had his mother and father to
encourage him despite being
a straight a students.
He thought that as a black person,
there truly was no point
in continuing at school.
He dropped out in order to begin
working and start a new life.
When he was 17 Malcomb moved to
New York City to live in Harlem.
He got a job doing dishes at a restaurant
and is charismatic person now as he
helps him make a lot of friends of all
races, why men begins to approach him,
asking if he had any drugs,
if he could hook them up with black girls.
Since people were already making
that assumption based on stereotypes,
he decided that he might as
well take advantage of it.
This started is successful side hustle of
being a pimp, a robber or rackets here,
and a drug dealer. He
befriended John L. Roy Sanford,
fellow dishwasher at Jimmy's chicken
shack and haul who aspired to be a
professional comedian. Both
men had reddish has say
Sanford was called Chicago,
red off to his hometown and
little was known as Detroit red.
He has later at Sanford
became famous as Red Fox.
One of littles best friends was a
teenage boy. He had his first name,
Malcolm Jarvis,
the two of them.
They hustle together and they would
go out to jazz clubs at night.
They was zoot suits and impress. The
ladies with their dance moves for a wall.
They were raking in a loss of money and
having the time of that lives in 1949
the two Malcolm's were both dating
white girls who they met at a nightclub.
These girls had very rich parents and
they were bored cup to maniacs looking for
a bit of excitement.
They encouraged the Malcolm's to form a
Bonnie and Clyde star ganged together.
They would let the boys
know whenever their parents,
neighbors were on vacation and then they
would all go and steal from the homes
together. Malcolm, Mr felt that he was
playing a grown up version of Robin Hood,
but when the group was caught,
it caused a huge outrage in the
courts because of them mixed races.
No one could believe that to rich white
girls could have possibly been at the
masterminds behind the robberies,
and of course their parents
could afford to get them lawyers.
So the girlfriend's lied
under roof cleaning,
that they didn't even know the boys and
that they had been kidnapped and forced
to participate in the
robbery. Both Malcolm's, we're
only 20 years at the time,
and they both received the maximum
sentence of eight to 10 years in prison.
The women were able to walk free without
any punishments. When he was in prison,
Malcon realized that many black men were
totally innocent and had been falsely
accused of crimes.
These innocent men,
they turned to God in order
to cope with their feet.
But this made Malcolm very angry.
He had become a staunch atheist because
he believed that if there were truly a
god, he wouldn't let black people
suffer like they were suffering.
He yells at other inmates.
We being stupid enough to believe in God
and claims that even if he did exist,
he had abandoned his black people
completely. An elder inmate,
John Bembry could see that he was
very angry and in a lot of pain.
So he told Malcolm this.
If he could not escape through religion,
he should turn to books instead because
it could help transport his mind to
other places.
Malcolm took this advice and began to
read every book in the Prison Library for
the first time in his life.
He was reading Shakespeare and all
of the other great works since he,
Trudy did escape into his own mind,
often being in prison for some time.
One of Malcolm's brothers wrote to him
explaining that his siblings and finally
reunited and they were attending meetings
of a group called the nation of Islam,
Malcolm right bags that he
did not believe in any god,
but there's brother promised him
that if he started praying to Allah,
he would get out of prison early.
His brother sent him a book
written by Elijah Muhammad,
who was the leader of the nation of Islam.
In his book,
Elijah Muhammad wrote that black people
were already going through that own
version of hell on earth and that's
white men with ad demonic oppresses the
nation of Islam shed some
of the traditional beliefs
of Middle Eastern Islam,
but it mostly focuses on raising the
confidence of black people saying this.
They were actually the superior race.
He encouraged them to educate themselves,
become self sufficient,
and have pride in their race.
This was basically the way that Malcolm
had been raised by his parents and it
was clear that Elijah Muhammad's teachings
paralleled those of Marcus Garvey.
Malcolm decided to give the
nation of Islam the chance,
even though he had never
set foot in a mosque before.
He started to grow his beard,
refuse to eat pork.
Parkins prayed to other several
times a day. The prison guards,
they tried to stop him,
so he wrote to the governor demanding
that is an American citizen.
He should have the right
to choose his religion.
Say positive at large in Muhammad's
teachings was to stop trying to please or
integrate into white society and take
pride in being an African American.
Some Alpha dropped his last name,
little which was given to his ancestors
when they were slaves as a sign of
ownership.
He had no idea what his family is real
African tribal name had been so he
decided to replace it with a simple x
representing the missing family history
that had been stolen from him.
He lays you wrote for me,
my ex replaced the white
slave master name of little,
which some blue eyed devil names little
imposed upon my potato forebears.
Now there's,
he went by Malcolm x.
He started a debate team and the prison
and men would go to listen to him speak.
He was such an amazing
speaker that several other
men were convinced to join the
nation of Islam and they
began to pray together.
Instead of being meek and
subservient to the white gods,
they stood tool and suddenly seemed Fomo,
confidence,
and powerful than ever before.
This made the prison guards nervous.
They thought that Malcolm x might
have too much control and those he was
released. He would incite
riots and start a race war.
The warden notifying the FBI and he was
placed on a watch list and denied parole
despite his good behavior.
He was finally released from prison after
six years and he immediately became a
Minnesota for the nation of
Islam and Detroit, Michigan.
He was so good at speaking that he was
given the position of national spokesman
when he first got started.
Elijah Mohammed only had managed to gather
500 members into the nation of Islam
in the United States in 1952 but once
Malcolm x toward and gave speeches,
it quickly grew to over 30,000 members.
By 1963 Malcolm x was constantly trying
to build up the confidence of African
American people.
He encouraged black people to feel proud
of that natural hair and their dark
skin and never trying to compare
themselves to white people.
He encouraged them to open their own
businesses in Harlem, barbershops,
butches restaurants and clothing stores
owned by black people sprang up for the
very first time in American history,
this box,
a trend across the nation
and lack of businesses.
They became commonplace
in all major cities.
It was at this point that Malcolm x
met and fell in love with a woman named
Betty Sanders.
Since the two they got married,
they would go on to have six daughters
together. Malcolm started a fraternity,
agree of cooled the fruit of Islam.
These were men who were like a private
militia. They were always clean.
Cartons were brand new suits with pride.
They would and he taught them
to never use violence and less.
It was in self defense.
After all,
peaceful civil rights protestors
were being hosed down,
beaten by police and attacks by God dogs.
He believed that if they wanted
to get things done successfully,
they needed to prepare for the possibility
that if they began to fight for their
rights, it might cause a war between black
and white people. The fruit of Islam.
They were taught never to attack fast,
but they should not accept
a beating without fighting.
Back on April the 26th 1957 one of
the members of their congregation,
Johnson x Henson,
was taking suits out of his car in front
of the Muslim 10 building in New York
City. Police officers saw this and
they accused him of stealing the suits.
When he tried to explain that
they belong to the congregation,
they beat him with heavy clubs and
detained him in the police station without
giving him medical attention.
Malcolm x seat rushed in the police
station and asked to see Johnson.
When they told him to leave, he told
the officers to look out the window.
A line of men wearing crisp suits,
sunglasses and for doors were
all standing out on the streets.
It was an entire army of the fruit
of Islam ready for Malka disorders.
When they finally agreed
to let him see Johnson.
Malcolm demanded that they
call an ambulance because
he was bleeding heavily and
dying of his injuries. The militia
followed them all the way to the hospital,
but it was confirmed that
Johnson would survive.
Now waved his hands and
the militia dispersed,
preventing what would
have been a massive right.
This terrified the NYP d and it was clear
that even though they had no idea who
he was until that day, he was a
very powerful man in New York City.
One officer was quoted as saying,
no man should have that much power.
It needs to try to sue the city to
pay for Hinton's medical expenses,
but they denied everything.
Malcolm x decided to travel across the
country and convert new people to the
nation of Islam.
They eventually opened to Muslim temple
in Los Angeles in 1962 and almost
identical situation
happened all over again.
A man named Ronald Stokes was taking the
dry cleaning out of a car in front of
the mosque.
The police accused him of stealing the
suits and when he tried to explain,
he put his hands up and they
again shooting him at close range.
11 men rush to help their friends and
tried to pull the police officers away,
but they were all arrested and they
were all accused of being part of a
so-called mob in the local newspaper.
It was printed that this was a Muslim
riot in courts and the police officer who
shot and killed Ronald stakes and method
that he knew that stokes was unarmed,
but that he shot him first because he
raised his hands in a menacing way and
just 25 minutes,
the white jury decided that this was
enough justification to murder him and the
officer he was set free. Immediately
after this man got away with murder,
11 members of Nation of Islam were found
guilty of assaulting a police officer
and they were all sent to prison.
After this incidence,
Malcolm x realize that the fight was
too much for even the nation of Islam to
handle.
He calls for all black people to come
together regardless of their religion.
In order to fight for civil
rights following stags, his death.
Malcolm x gave one of his most
famous speeches. We are oppressed,
we are exploited, we are downtrodden.
We are denied not just civil rights,
but human rights.
So the only way we are going to get
some of this oppression and exploitation
away from us is to come
together against a common enemy.
For years, Malcolm x was the
face of the nation of Islam,
and even though he was spreading
the teachings of his mentor,
Elijah Muhammad's the man, rarely did
any of the work himself. Once a month,
Malcolm would visit Chicago to give money
to Mohammad for his living expenses.
One day he ran into three young women
who were knocking on Muhammad's door.
They were demanding that he give them
money for food and child support.
He learned from them that Elijah Muhammad
had cheated on his wife and eight
children with six different secretaries.
The girls were all only 16
or 17 years old at the time.
So this was also a statutory rape.
He was not taking responsibility for
his kids and he had ruins the lives of
these young women. Malcolm
Austin, Elijah's son wireless.
If this was actually true, when's he
admitted that he and his mother knew,
but they were in denial.
The followers were so blindly faithful
to Elijah Mohammad's that even when the
word spread that the founder of the
religion was a liar and a hypocrite,
they accused Wallace of
lying about his father.
Mohammed confirmed the room is in 1963
attempting to justify his behavior by
referring to precedents
set by biblical prophets.
Malcolm x did not leave nation
of Islam right away though,
but he did distance himself.
He focused more on preaching about
the civil rights movements for a time.
He thought that he had been tricked into
living a lie since he was struggling
with this Muslim faith.
Malcolm x took a pilgrimage to Makkah in
Saudi Arabia in 1964 he was shocked to
see people of all races making
the pilgrimage together.
Elijah Muhammad's was teaching
that white people were evil,
but once Malcolm saw
what true Islam was like,
he knew this was proof that Brotherhood
amongst the human race could exist.
He'd seen it with his own eyes.
He no longer believe that Martin Luther
King Jr was preaching a pipe dream.
He was inspired to give himself a new
name. I'll hogene Malik, I'll Shahbaz.
He spent an additional three
weeks traveling around,
so several countries in Africa.
When you were to the United States,
he was a completely changed man.
He no longer preach that white men
were devils and he said that all people
needed to come together and live in peace.
On march the eighth 1964 he announced
that he was leaving the nation of Islam
and he exposed all of the corruption
that he had kept secret. Until then,
he can bad the religion
to a mafia crime ring.
This he no longer wanted to be a part of.
He said that if anyone
wants to follow him,
he was going to start up his own
Muslim group called Muslim mosque inc.
This was a huge threat to Elijah
Muhammad's livelihood. Of course,
and if at a target on Malcolm's back,
are you not perhaps afraid of what might
happen to you as a result of making
these revelations? Oh yes. I
probably am a dead man already.
Malcolm received death threats,
but he kept moving and began traveling
with a new found motivation to bring
peace to all nations.
He became an international diplomat and
traveled to 14 African countries meeting
with 11 heads of state.
He wants it to discuss the treatments of
African Americans and the human rights
issues that they were facing in America.
He encouraged the United Nations step
in to help black people in the United
States since he believed
that the American government,
we're not doing enough to support the
rights of black people, the FBI and CIA.
They were following him wherever he went
and he was receiving harassing phone
calls on a daily basis.
Elijah Muhammad told Boston Minister
Louis acts later known as Louis Farrakhan
that hypocrites like Malcolm
should have their heads cut off,
and the April 10th edition of Muhammad
speaks featured a cartoon depicting
Malcolm x is bouncing severed heads.
His house in New York,
it was later firebombs and his wife
and daughters were very nearly killed.
Malcolm x publicly announced that he
knew Elijah Muhammad had ordered a hit on
his life and that he was going
to die soon. Unfortunately,
it was right in 1965 Malcolm x was
giving a speech in New York City when a
member of the nation of Islam shot him
in the chest at close range with a sawed
off shotgun to other men,
five semiautomatic handguns.
He had 21 gunshot wounds on his body.
He was 39 years old or an activist.
Ossie Davis delivered the
eulogy describing Malcolm
x's are shining black prince
who didn't hesitate to
die because he loved us.
So Malcolm x was only just beginning
his new goal of attempting to change the
lives of African Americans everywhere,
and there is no way of knowing just how
much you would have accomplished if he
was given that chance before his death.
He had admitted that he had made a
mistake by preaching hate against white
people when he first got started and he
was ready and willing to go along with
Martin Luther King and the civil rights
movement if he were still alive today.
There is no telling just how much more
he would have accomplished even in his
short time on earth.
He inspired African Americans to be the
people proud of their skin color because
of him. Black people everywhere began to
demand more for themselves and from the
expectations of everyone in their country.
No matter what religion
someone is subscribed to,
they can still find inspiration from
listening to his speeches about human
rights and whether they know it or not.
There is so much in American society
that would have never existed without the
influence of Malcolm x. So I already
have you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do give us a thumbs
up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just
like this several days a week. Also,
if you're looking for something
else to watch right now,
why not check out another
channel of mine called today?
I found out you find that link to below
and as always, thank you for watching.